ed a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo vi dò io sono qua vj oggi
siamo su faceva più fuoco una volta sta
merda va bene [ __ ] ok ragazzi e
utilizzate mari che prima funzionava
bene volevo farmi intro fantastica ma è
uscita di merda quindi non mi importa
siamo si beve rendering nightmares che è
un videogame fantastico che ho visto su
kickstarter e tra l'altro vi lascio alla
pagina di kick start nella descrizione
del video nel caso vogliate votarlo in
poche parole ci sono soltanto due tasti
c'è la barra spaziatrice quelli per
muoversi va bene che poi sono cinque non
importa da iniziamo possiamo farcela
sono fa vj piacere se questo è quello
che succede se mangiate troppo e
caramelle prima di andare a nanna
andateci piano maledizione o chiave come
inizio non era bellissimo ragazzi sono
un tizio molto brutto
c'è un taglio di capelli che fantastico
tra l'altro però non so che sinceramente
non ho mai visto un gioco in questa
grafica cioè disegnata così ma va bene
ma qualcosa prendi una foto questo tasto
non ho messo ma non funzionava bene lo
apriamo le porte si e le porte le apre
va bene così
va bene non so dove sto andando non so
anche perché no vabbè ma la grafica è
fantastica cioè io non ho mai giocato a
un videogame tra i quadri sono stupendi
c'è nota che ce lo slider ragazzi lo
slider man è appurato che i sogni
[ __ ] videogioco qua dentro non c'è
nulla vabbè andiamo avanti così perché
ci sono ci sono uccelli blender man sui
quadri non si sa perché va bene prendi
c'è anche il quadro e lo slang me qui e
poi prendere no ragazzi non ci trovo un
senso a questo gioco va beh abbiamo
trovato la cantina quindi ragazzi
sappiamo dove andare se dobbiamo pagarci
addosso perfetto qua ancora più buio per
cos'è c'è la porta sbarrata adesso
giochiamo a a zombie perfetto vai così
non si sa perché la porta sbarrata ma
noi andiamo dall'altra parte non ho idea
di che cosa aspettarmi da questo
videogame perché non ho visto nulla
praticamente quindi non so che cosa sto
cioè non so che cosa sto ragazzo non
capito che cosa devo fare io sto andando
avanti inutilmente sta diventando tutto
più scuro non so come spiegarlo va bene
così prima o poi succederà qualcosa sono
sicuro
è successo c'è una [ __ ] ombra di
fuori bene così forse come al solito me
ne devo stare zitto quando quando dico
le cose succedono è sempre così c'è
praticamente quando e scarabocchiato
dovrebbe rappresentare le parti più buie
c'è dove non c'è luce quindi va bene
noi andiamo completamente dove buio
fantastico ragazzi abbiamo incontrato
un'ombra c'è una bottiglia una bottiglia
voglio black arti adesso sì no no tira
che succederà qualcosa di nuovo c'è una
lettera la lettera prendila però non è
anche ai ragazzi non prendiamo nulla e
sto gioco
camminiamo e basta il mio unico scopo
fino adesso è stato andare avanti senza
far nulla perché non si può veramente
far niente a parte entrare in qualche
stanza così occasionalmente sarà ecco
non c'è più nulla questa è l'ultima
porta dove siamo
e cazzo siamo finiti i ragazzi non lo so
neanch'io poi entriamo di qua non adesso
è iniziano entra nelle porte e troppo
buio non vedo un calcio e una scritta
sul muro mai
my my god ma non leggo una mazza c'è una
scritta sul muro ma non riesco a
leggerla noi andiamo avanti
non vedo non vedo nulla la vera gatto
rendiamo indietro talmente devo
accendere le luci da qualche parte tanto
come posso mi faceva schifo quindi
possiamo tranquillamente andare avanti
poi ci tornerò a tanto cos'è una candela
ga è l'unica cosa colorata che ci sto
gioco la candela
posso prenderla sì sì abbiamo la luce e
luce fu ragazzi abbiamo la [ __ ] luce
posso entrare in quella maledettissima
camera adesso tratto sembra garibaldi
quello nella foto non si sa perché va
bene io non ho trovato ancora un senso a
questo gioco
ho visto un ombra e mi è bastato doveva
tornare indietro abbiano capito
io non vorrei entrarci qui dentro ve lo
dico subito ma sono costretto buongiorno
io non sapevo che avevo visto qualcosa a
terra ma giuro che non ti avevo
riconosciuto tratto sono io ci sono io
che quello che sto comandando è lo
stesso tizio che c'è a terra
my god avoletto bene wire è più forte
che mai
forse perché mi hai abbandonato
io non ti ho abbandonato amico mio ho
preso st kanda allora c'era l'accendino
poteva usare questa ma non funziona
quindi è inutile che provava ad
accenderlo prima scusa vabbè comunque
sia c'è un tizio morto a terra
e cosa c'è di altri 60 anni e c'è sempre
garibaldi sulla foto va bene torniamo
indietro perché non ha senso
comunque sia ti auguro buona dormita e
me ne vado
perfetto ragazzi usciamo dico perché non
mi piace sostanza mi piace questo posto
non mi piace che cosa sta succedendo
torniamo indietro non so che cosa devo
fare
adesso è diventato tutto buio non vedo
una ceppa cioè si è oscurato tutto
ma ho fatto prima vedere tutto c'è
adesso sia scurato tutto non c'è più
niente eccezione
pazzo era quella ragazzi cos'è sta roba
cos'è ragazzi via di qui vieni qui
veloce veloce veloce veloce veloce
veloce accendi la luce garibaldi aiuto
aiuto derivati fu ferito o ferite in un
corridoio ok
nel caso siamo ok ragazzi sta diventando
veramente assurdo perché ci sono dei
teschi disegnati sul muro gli ho notati
adesso usciamo di qua basta adesso vado
a togliere le travi da quella porta di
merda
togliamo ste travi immediatamente c'è
una tizia che mi seguiva prima denunce
più via
non c'è lo slang dal ministro gioco c'è
una tizia
cioè va bene non importa andiamo avanti
ci ho paura di ciò che inquieta per
questo possa essere in 2d con una
grafica disegnata che a mio parere è
fantastica perché disegnato un gioco non
lo mettono gli effetti sonori di merda
ok usciamo di qua siamo da pochissimo
posto subito come si fa uscire qua c'è
mimì fico dell'orologio aprì la porta
che non è una porta un orologio
magnifico lì dentro piuttosto giochi
giorno ragazzi cioè ogni [ __ ] notte
che mi alzo dal mio letto per andare a
prendere l'acqua in frigo faccio lo
stesso identico percorso c'è va beh non
so che dove siamo adesso
noi siamo finiti insomma di nuovo nel
corridoio principale sto di nuovo
tornano indietro perfetto torniamo
completamente indietro ecco la porta da
aifo cast e travi di merda no neanche
cioè non si può uscire bello barricarsi
in casa quando il problema in realtà sta
in casa 44 non c'era andato prima
presumo che io debba andarci perché era
troppo buio perfetto non ci poteva
entrare prima perché era troppo buio di
sicuro però adesso ci per sentire raga
io non so perché ci sto entrando
ugualmente anche se una candela la cosa
non mi consola per niente perché c'è un
ascia perché c'è una [ __ ] non può
usare la candela gesù santo ragazzi o
un'ascia
io ho un ascia si è spenta la torcia
ragazzi primo che mi si presenta la
maglia
che è successo sono sveglio sono sveglio
fermi ragazzi è stato tutto un sogno è
stato tutto un sogno calmi non è
successo nulla
ho di nuovo lascia era un sogno però
lascia cielo adesso prendo stage a di
merda se si ripresenta con la bambina
del cazzo saltare tutto vabbè non lo so
se sono sulle bambole però non ho capito
neanche se una bambola che si muove
quella che ho incontrato prima ma tratto
si cuoce un'altra porta c'è una porta
qui a destra che prima non ha aperto due
doc cos'è sta roba
devo controllare lì dentro sono siete
veramente convinti che debba farlo non
controlla perfetto non controlla qui
dentro che mi consola parecchio
probabilmente lo vedremo verso la fine
anche se sinceramente immagino che cosa
c'è avendo un ascia piena di sangue e
vedendo lavandino sporco di sangue posso
immaginare che cosa c'è lì dentro usate
la fantasia ragazzi non so dove sto
andando ancora ci stanno ragazzi si
stanno spegnendo le luci dietro di me
garibaldi spegne le lanterne ti ho visto
ma edizione va beh dobbiamo andare
avanti
continuano a spegnersi delle luci non so
perché
va bene si vede che non ha pagato la
bolletta basta ma non fa ridere petrolio
questo rumore di catene di merda
ho sentite c'è un rumore di catene
bruttissimo che cazzo solo se catene
raga settore del catene va beh c'è un
cuore non era così lungo corridoio prima
ragazzi sta andando avanti non si sa
perché non si saluta la porta sponda sta
merda rega fuori di qui fuori da sto
[ __ ] posto via prima che si spenga
tutto sono dove sono in soffitta
buongiorno io le giuro che non volevo
disturbarla stavo sono passato con
un'ascia per il puro caso sta dormendo
come linea perché dobbiamo disturbarla
noi siamo con te questo questo è peggio
di goku sull teletrasporto raga hai
raggiunto la fine della demo grazie per
aver giocato no non potete farmi finire
il suo gioco così
no ragazzi e fantastico devo avere
assolutamente la versione completa è
epico non giocherò di sicuro quando
uscirà anche ragazzi se vi è piaciuto
come al solito asha documento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come in
ogni video trovata una descrizione sensi
da prestiti iscrivetevi non ci vediamo
in un prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]